rocky may have gotten the barbecue but
look what i got right here we're talking
sweets for your sweetheart and for that
we brought in the executive pastry chef
for the red rock casino gerard fabiani
thank you so much for being here well
thank you so much for having me so love
is in the air and to celebrate this year
valentine
green valley ranch bake shop and a
redwood bake shop
put on some
beautiful desserts and some very
specific items beautiful display and
this is a big time of year right
absolutely so
we wanted to make special of course once
uh once again so we made some
unbreakable hearts we have some new
teddy bears so we have a range of
desserts and i think it's such a
fantastic idea for your companion or
your lover to to celebrate with your
valentine i love it and these teddy
bears are no ordinary teddy bears you
get to do something fun with each other
absolutely are we gonna play with this
one yes okay so tell us what this is
what we do here so we're gonna like glue
the top of it okay
and then i am going to let you break
that so as you see they are filled with
uh leonardo do you see that guys which
camera you want on three
so there we go
yes oh it's one sorry okay so boom we're
going to put that on top of that
absolutely
we're gonna glue a little bit over here
okay so it doesn't move
just like that okay and then i'm gonna
let you do this with a mallet all right
just to have fun this segment got better
all right absolutely all right just slam
it you just slam it okay and then you
can eat like all right
there you go fantastic and this is
edible too this is edible oh that's
fantastic this is one of many i mean
this is a beautiful spread here thank
you so much what are some of your
favorites well i i would say that i
really like the the cheesecake you know
the separation of the red the red glaze
and the white glaze with gold it really
really makes a an effect on it and of
course we have like an offering of a
stacked cookie dough with some whipped
cream and some fruits shaped as a heart
so
just beautiful on top of being delicious
how did we end up lucky enough to have
you here in the states you grew up in
france i did yes i am originally from
france from the south of france and how
did you end up in las vegas well it is a
company who decided to uh send me in the
u.s and uh first it was in florida and
now i'm in las vegas well we are
thrilled you're here because we get to
enjoy your work it is beautiful so thank
you thank you so much thanks so much for
being here and uh i hope people take
advantage of all the opportunities you
have at the red rock as well as so they
can order this online the breakable
heart and the teddy bear so the
breakable heart goes for 75
and the teddy bear for i'm sorry for 85
and then the teddy bear 75
this one is at the green valley ranch
a showcase at lucky penny we have two
locations of course and